it is an honor for me that you are honoring me
with this sustainability
award today
it is a kind of recognition of the
work of the european commission
and for me it is also an encouragement
that we stay on the path we have taken in fact
protecting the climate and
nature is a priority  top of the agenda
hans carl von
carlowitz recognized this more than 300 years ago
and what he wrote down back then could
now be the guiding principle for many a commission proposal
i quote we must
not exploit nature without limits or
just another quote from him  if we
can treat nature and its raw materials with respect and care, we
as a society can survive in the
long run karlovit’s thinking is also the
basis of the european green deal which is at the
heart of my political program
the european green deal is europe’s
new growth strategy
it gives more back to the planet than
she takes him the goal is at the top
to make europe the first
climate-neutral continent in the world by 2050
we can be brave we are
well positioned in europe we have the
science we have highly innovative companies
who my strong industry and not to
forget we already have
millions of citizens in europe who
rely on sustainability in your everyday life as a matter of course because you are convinced
that you are doing the right thing
let's make europe the
first climate-neutral continent together